le premier serait alexander petrov le
deuxième ruslans bosch i love
ils sont russes dans la quarantaine les
autorités britanniques sont aujourd'hui
convaincus que ce sont eux qui ont
empoisonné les skripal et que l'attak a
été commandée par les plus hautes
sphères du pouvoir de la russie qui ont
seuls le gr eu le glou c'est le service
secret pour lequel sergueï skripal était
colonel avant de faire défection aux
russes pour se joindre aux anglais une
attaque horrible minutieusement préparée
a dit le premier ministre mais devant le
parlement
selon les centaines d'heures de vidéos
étudier les deux hommes seraient arrivés
à londres de moscou le 2 mars et
seraient repartis deux jours plus tard
les mains sales c'est dans ce petit
hôtel de londres où les deux hommes ont
séjourné que des traces de l'agent
toxiques ne vit tschopp ont été
retrouvés du la police et c'est dans un
petit flacon de parfum contrefaits comme
celui ci que le poison aurait été
transporté c'est l'outil parfait pour
disperser le poison au pied de la porte
de la famille skripal dit l'enquêteur et
ses photos des deux hommes auraient été
captées par des caméras de surveillance
tout près de la résidence le grand rue
si la réaction a été immédiate et sans
équivoque en juillet d'un habitué aux
manipulations mensonges c'est faux tout
ne rime à rien à déclaré la porte parole
des affaires étrangères
mariage à la roma tara si grave et elle
a tenu à rappeler en entrevue que tout
citoyen russe qui voyage au royaume uni
doit fournir des empreintes digitales
nous avons demandé aux britanniques de
nous les fournir dit elle ils ont refusé
sur les plateaux de télévision à moscou
toute la journée on s'est payé la tête
de terry sommet et de ses photos les
allégations sont ridiculisés pourtant la
carsci fall a eu de sérieuses
répercussions sur la russie d froid
diplomatique des sanctions économiques
et aujourd'hui tu es sommet a invité ses
alliés allaient durcir une fois de plus
c'est difficile de prévoir jusqu'où ira
la communauté internationale pour punir
la russie davantage et les chances que
ces deux hommes soient arrêtés et
traduits en justice sont pratiquement
nulles si thammarat intéresse coup
radio-canada moscou